fabiano caruana with christian carrillo
fabi congratulations you needed an
armageddon in the first match a playoff
in the second one but you finished
lanier off in only two games how do you
feel right now oh this is uh this is a
great feeling especially since i was
under so much pressure the whole game
i was very worried because my position
was dubious
i was down on time so
yeah i was very worried and
but i think i defended reasonably well i
mean he might have had some decent
winning chances at some point but i
didn't see anything very clear-cut and i
was very
happy with this um
uh what was the move i played three
three perhaps oh well e3 i was i was
happy to find but i wasn't sure about
this endian so i still wasn't like at
least i was happy that i didn't
you know lose uh the pawn but i was only
sure that it was going to be okay
um
at the end when he found this f5 stuff
and
i'd like to just go through it i'd just
like to bring you to this position fabi
and quiz you hear not about the theory
that took place beforehand because
bishop f6
really stuck uh you start you stopped
here because uh you
recognize that you're on the defensive
and you've got to find the the right way
you took a lot of time you went queen f6
take us through your thought process if
you don't mind well at first i was
thinking i should find some way to
equalize after queen of six c3 but then
i couldn't find it so i started to
um
think about g takes f6 yes which is
very anti-positional very risky
obviously my king becomes much weaker
but at least i i'm i'm supporting my e
pawn but after f3 f5
um
take take and queen e1 i didn't find
anything which was good
he's very quickly getting an attack with
knight g4
queen c3 all sorts of things
uh so i thought
that i might just lose here right and i
thought this e3
um
like i wasn't worried at all about fe3 i
thought i'm
barely worse there after 95 because uh
suddenly my night which was so bad has
such a beautiful outpost and kind of
dominating his night as you know
simultaneously yeah
i mean i'm still worse but i i felt like
i could defend that and
and i was just happy when i saw this
queen e697 idea
so he sort of forced i thought to play
queen b3 because if i get 97 knight of
five i don't think i'm worse
like i think we were thinking about
queen a4
as a possible move for him was it 97
christian and perhaps even better would
have been queen to b1 i think the idea
is more or less the same that after 97
you go queen to e4
yeah i didn't see that idea that that
might have been very good
and if you exchange the queens then the
knight has to reroute back which is
probably just going to be a pawn up yeah
so it's actually it kind of transposes
in both cases queen a4 queen e4 against
97 and in case of queen b1 also
uh
the queen b1 looks a little
weird to say
and it also allows rook a8 right as an
extra option so a4 just feels like the
much more natural move if you see this
idea of queen a4 queen before did you
feel that after queen b3 you're back in
the game then suddenly no no not at all
i just spent all my time considering
queen b3 okay i basically didn't
consider other moves uh
and so at least i could quickly
play my next few moves
i was pretty happy that instead of
playing let's say the natural knight a5
which i think after b4 is very
unpleasant instead of rook d1
knight a5 b4
knight c4 b3 knight d2
um it's actually very important that
rook d2 it would i think rook d2
might be okay but rookie one is is
winning i was i thought rookie three two
he saw the rookie but rookie one yeah i
think that's right you region maybe
rookie three is also very good but this
it looks like your position's hanging
yeah so knight d2 i think is forced
uh after b3 b3 and id2 and now my knight
on b3 is terribly placed so he plays
knight takes e3
um or even
or maybe not even 93 maybe rookie three
is even better because then he gets to
work on the seventh immediately right um
at any of these positions where your
knight is on a
really lousy square and he has his rook
on the seventh and here is our champions
of the other bracket in the other
category arena crush does draw her game
against alice lee she wins that match
exactly
this is the 5 000 bonus very very nice
our congratulations to irina she still
has one more match to go
this was something you were trying to
avoid uh fabi yeah that's why i played
what i did
and i didn't see the very obvious
problem with it so i thought at least
um he'll have to dig deep to find
something very strong here
it was actually right here that he there
was an extraordinary
moment to play this move
i was wondering we were wondering yeah
maybe you had analyzed
uh
this uh kind of crazy prospect i just
thought that it's very unlikely someone
goes for this
i mean yeah rook b1
and then
d7 i think is what we were d7 to stop
the knight from
jumping out
but it's hard to imagine black loses
this i mean maybe it's well on a big day
right
what's um your pieces are a little
frozen on the first rank yeah but black
has useful moves like king g8
you know b5 or even g5 if you if you
want to stop that whole f4 stuff okay um
although i'd like to get b5 then just to
stop those pawns a bit
from advancing fair enough
but i feel like it should be a draw i
mean even if we sack the knight back at
some point and
liquidate a few palms it should be like
a a dry shrug ending
so yeah i think what he did was much
more
more human approach okay
uh because what he did do is play rookie
two and you got to this
position
and
i think we thought after rookie one your
chances for a draw was super high you
still felt
you're under pressure though um
yeah i i still thought i was in a lot of
danger because my king is getting mated
but i thought that objectively it should
be okay your king is getting made okay
so f4
and yeah f5 was a strong move and i was
just very happy with c6 because if i
play rook c3 and id5
maybe it's okay but um his knight is
very often coming to g6
and
so f5 sorry so if you
allow the knight this is where you're
getting mated this is the yeah this was
the pattern that you might be i mean it
might be okay i thought maybe rook c4
but
yeah i thought even if he plays like
rookie seven and collects c7 with the
knight he still has the
the attack on the king exactly he's not
even down material so there's a
checkmate threat right now well king g89
and yeah yeah
very oops so you liked your 6 c6 move
yeah i thought it was a very important
move because now his knight has nowhere
to go
like if knight g4 there's always this h5
uh and then 95 knight d3
stuff or i mean 93 person
um
or well here i can probably play rook c
three immediately oh no no sorry an id3
that's correct yeah
knight d3 and then his king has can't
attack my knight because of the work on
the e file and then a tribe next move
and i kick his knight back
exactly yeah so after that i was pretty
sure i should hold this game
our congratulations once again uh you're
saving your best uh for the very end of
the tournament as you avoid a playoff
today and uh who are you looking forward
to in the finals finals
oh i i don't know i don't think that
there's any clear favorite in in the
match it will be lavon versus lanier
yeah i mean it'll be your event it's
also a uh
let's say rematch which is kind of funny
and
and yeah it'll just be interesting to
watch i mean they're two two very
uh very great players and um
and both of them have very good chances
to to make it to the final
all right gabby well thank you
congratulations and uh we'll see enjoy
your rest day thank you winner of the
champions bracket fabiano caruana an
extra 10 grand for him we've already
been congratulations uh dinner
reservations
and his name yeah